[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lord voldemort in ferry
and the practice of necromancy the word
in fairy is the plural of
inferious which comes from the latin
form underneath
below the and very are described on
pottermore as follows
and inferious is a corpse that has been
reanimated by a dog wizard's curse
it becomes a grisly puppet and may be
used as an expendable servant by the
dark wizard in question
the most obvious sign that one is facing
in inferious rather than a living human
are the white and cloudy eyes snape in
the half blood prince
backs up this definition the inferius is
a corpse that has been reanimated by a
dark wizard's spells
it is not alive it is merely used like a
puppet to do the wizards bidding
pottermore continues the spells used to
reanimate a human body
are much more complex than those used
for instance to make inanimate objects
fly
the inferiors may be cursed to respond
lethally if disturbed
to kill indiscriminately and to
undertake perilous jobs for its master
but with all of that aside i want to
discuss a couple of things
first i want to discuss how exactly the
fairy are created
what's involved with reanimating the
dead then i want to discuss who the
original creator of the inferior is
we commonly associate the inferior with
voldemort and we know that he creates
some
but is he the original creator is he
responsible for their existence
did he invent that magic we know that
there were masses of inferi in
the cave a cave near the seaside the tom
riddle would visit with the orphanage as
a child
it was at the same cave that tom riddle
would terrorize other orphans
and later hide salazar southern's locket
one of his horcruxes
the cave was the perfect place for him
ferry to exist and the half-blood prince
describes harry and dumbledore's run in
with the cave
perfectly an eerie sight met their eyes
they were standing on the edge of a
great black lake
so vast that harry could not make out
the distinct banks in a cavern so high
that the ceiling
too was out of sight a misty greenish
light shone far away
from what looked like the middle of the
lake it was reflected in the completely
still water below
the greenish glow and the light from the
two ones were the only things that broke
the otherwise velvety blackness
though their rays did not penetrate as
far as harry would have expected
the darkness was somehow denser than
normal darkness
so dumbledore and harry had found the
cave but what still stood between them
in the horcrux was a lake
and in very infested lake separated the
entrance of the cave from the horcrux
any attempt to use a summoning charm to
get the horcrux would cause one more and
ferry to leap out of the water
to block the spell's effect if the water
is disturbed the inferior would emerge
and attempt to drag the intruder into
the water to drown we know that
voldemort filled the lake within ferry
when he put the horcrux there originally
he never expected that anyone would ever
discover the lake as it was inaccessible
by boat
but placed additional defenses there
just in case we know that regulus black
was dragged into the lake
as well as creature but was the lake
cursed so that anyone who entered its
waters would turn
into an and furious or did voldemort
turn them into an inferior when he later
found their drowned body
the following excerpt from the half
blood prince seems to indicate that
harry thought so
but though gashes appeared in their
sodden rags and their icy skin
they had no blood to spill they walked
on unfeeling
their shrunken hands outstretched
towards him and as he backed away still
farther
he felt arms and clothes from behind
thin fleshless arms
cold as death and his feet left the
ground as they lifted him and began to
carry him
slowly and surely back to the water and
he knew there would be no release
that he would be drowned and become one
more dead guardian for fragment
voldemort's shattered soul given that
creature and regulus black were the only
people to have ever discovered the
cave's location
and that they were met with an army of
inferi it's likely that voldemort must
have placed a large number
in ferry there originally however what
the above quote indicates
is that harry believed that anyone who
died in the cave would also become an
inferi
the cursed waters would turn them into
one the vast majority of the inferior
were homeless mongols that no one would
ever notice were missing
with a few witches and wizards sprinkled
in this is supported by this other
pottermore page
the inferior whom harry and dumbledore
encounter in the depth of the lake in
harry potter and half blood prince were
when alive mostly vagrant homeless
muggles whom voldemort had murdered for
the purpose
during his first rise to power although
some were the earthly remains of wizards
or witches
who disappeared without explanation
while i understand where harry is coming
from with his presumption that the lake
will turn him
into an ferry it's left a little bit
ambiguous as to
how the inferi are actually produced at
the cave whether it's done automatically
by the cursed water
or if it's done by voldemort after he
discovers the dead corpses
harry is still young and this is
complicated dark magic so it's unlikely
that he actually knew much about it
dumbledore a much older more powerful
wizard likely knew but never made any
sort of an indication to harry that this
was the case
while it seems like all the evidence
points to one thing that the lake
automatically creates in ferry i have
one issue with it
i always assume the creation of inferior
would require more conscious effort
it seems like such a complicated magical
feat and that it would require more of a
dedicated process
maybe it can be done either way and it
just depends on how you use the
necessary magic
next let's briefly look at who the
original creator of the inferi
actually is while voldemort and the
inferior commonly bundled together there
is evidence to support that he isn't
actually the one who created them
we know that he didn't create them
because their existence was known before
his time
in fact gaelic grindelwald the
terrorizer of the wizarding world that
preceded voldemort
is said to have wanted to create an army
of inferi himself
this was in 1899 many years before
voldemort was born
so does that mean that grindelwald
created them the short answer to that is
no
grindelwald never actually created in
ferry because he didn't know how he
thought that with the resurrection stone
he would be able to do it but he never
finds out so if it wasn't voldemort and
it wasn't grindelwald
who was it i have a couple of ideas my
first theory is that it was the same guy
that created the dementors the dark
wizard known as a christus
the chrysalis isn't particularly well
known but he certainly marked his place
in wizarding history
as he was a practitioner of the worst
kinds of dark arts imaginable
the types of magic that he performed and
experimented with made voldemort's
horcrux creation look fairly commonplace
very little is known about agaris other
than the fact that he was alive
during the 15th century and that he was
evil pure evil
no one even knows his nationality and
even if it was known i'm sure no one
would want to claim ownership of him
he was that bad echistus was the
original inhabitant of the island
fortress of azkaban
what we now know as the prison that
holds some of the darkest wishes and
wizards within its walls
while traveling in the 15th century the
crystal stumbled upon the island
which at the time had no infrastructure
to speak of when he first arrived it was
just a regular island
but he soon turned it into his own
little dark arts experiment hoping to
keep the location of the island secret
which was located in the north sea a
christus kicked things off by placing
concealment charms on the island
meaning that no one would be able to
intentionally find it after placing the
concealment charms on the island
the criticism began his dark art
experiments by luring
muggle sailors to the island then
torturing and eventually murdering them
before ever stepping foot on the island
the christmas was mad but after spending
some time there he became totally insane
as he had completely lost touch with
reality he became so wrapped up and
enthralled in his experimentation with
dark magic
that he had lost his mind and the poor
sailors that he lured to the island
witnessed it firsthand
in his madness it has been speculated
that a christus either unwittingly or
perhaps intentionally
created what we now know to be dementors
given his affinity for dark magic and
twisted experimentation
as well as the time period that he lived
in i think that he may have been
responsible for creating the original
magic
that created the inferi perhaps even
turning muggle sailors
into them my second theory is that it
was a wizard by the name of god low
godallah was one of the original elder
wand owners in fact he's the fourth
owner on record
after antioch emeric the evil and egbert
the egregious
godello used the elder one to push the
boundaries of magic and considered it to
be
his teacher allowing the one to help him
create all sorts of new spells
and conduct all sorts of experiments in
fact with the wand
godola wrote the book magic most evil
which we know exists in the hogwarts
library
magic most evil is thought to touch on
some of the most taboo dark magic around
but if you'll remember from harry potter
it still didn't contain any info on
horcruxes
given that this book was available in
the restricted section of hogwarts
and contained powerful dark magic i'm
sure voldemort studied it well
in fact i think that voldemort may have
learned how to conjure the inferior from
this book
making godlow responsible what do you
guys think
who do you think is responsible for
originally creating the
fairy let me know in the comment section
below until next time
remember there is plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be